love at first sight this kind of idea is
uh in part realizing very quickly that
you are great friends like I've had that
interesting experience a friendship
recently just it's not really friendship
but like oh you get each other with
humans not I'm not in romantic setting
right friendship yeah just friendship
but not but dare I say I felt that way
about you when we met right but we also
this dude's cool and he's smart and he's
funny and he's driven and he's giving
and he um and he's got an edge and
um like
I want to want to learn from want to
hang out with them like that I mean that
was the beginning of our friendship was
essentially you know that set of of
internal realization go on just keep
going that good people dresser yeah yeah
it just looks great shirtless on
Horseback yes no no no listen I mean
it's despite what some people might say
on the Internet it's a purely platonic
um friendship somebody said somebody
asked if Andrew has a girlfriend and
somebody says I think so and the the
third comment was this really like uh
breaks my heart like that uh Alex and
Andrew are not a not an item we are not
we are great friends but we are not an
item that's true it's official the um uh